MATT DELANEY: Hi, everyone.
So to start off this performance
talk, welcome to
potentially the juiciest
talk of the day.
You have people who are nice and
hangry before lunch here.
So just to be clear, there were
some kind of questions in
our moderation tool for this
panel that were kind of
overlapping with some
previous talks.
Because performance is
everywhere, right?
So if you look at some of the
questions relating to strictly
kind of network performance
things, those are mostly
covered in previous talks.
We'll mostly skip over those.
So now is your moment to put in
any juicier questions for
front end things, especially
graphics, and all the kind of
client side related performance
concerns you guys have.
So very quickly, I'm going
to run through.
We've got our opening speaker
here, Shane O'Sullivan.
So he's from Facebook,
a UI engineer.
He'll introduce himself
a little bit more.
We have Pavel Feldman
from Google.
He has worked on Chrome
dev tools.
And we have Rowan Beesje?
ROWAN BEENJE: Beenje.
MATT DELANEY: OK.
Knew I was going to
mess that one up.
So he works at FT Labs
with Andrew, and is
known for FT Scroller.
And then we have Chris Lord
from Mozilla, who is a
platform engineer for
Firefox mobile, so
primarily on Android.
So to start, Shane has a little
opening talk for us to
give us a bit of the
lay of the land of
performance at the moment.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN:
So hi, everyone.
I'm Shane O'Sullivan.
I work as a UI engineer
at Facebook.
I spent a couple of years
on the mobile site.
And now I work on our
business interfaces.
As he said, I'm here with
Ron, Chris, and Pavel.
And we're going to talk a bit
about some of the potholes
that are in the road to actually
having a performant
and fast and non-stuttery
website.
The two main things I'm really
going to talk about are
scrolling performance of complex
content, which is more
or less a stress test
for all rendering
platforms, not just web.
People also have a problem
with this on iOS.
God knows they have a problem
with it on Android.
And it more or less
forces us to solve
all the other problems.
And second one is memory
management,
which is quite related.
So to start off, let's
say what the goal is.
The goal is 60 frames per
second animation with no
dropped frames.
This is kind of the panacea.
Everybody wants to get here.
But it's not always possible.
So let's have a fallback goal.
And say, if we can get to 30
frames per second animations.
Make this reliable.
Make it have no stuttering.
This often is achievable.
And in a lot of user tests that
we've done, this tends to
perform a lot better than having
something that runs at
60 frames per second some of the
time, and even 40 frames
per second some of the time.
So if it goes from some 60 down
to 40, back up to 60,
people often see that as being
worse than just having a
steady 30 frames per
second animation.
So nice to have 60.
If we can get a steady 30,
you're generally in a fairly
good place.
So what's stopping
us getting there?
There's a whole bunch
of things.
To start of with is the
large DOM size.
If you want to take something
like Facebook newsfeed, you
have variable height rows made
up of large images, small
images, no images, variable
length text, everything
changes size, and you don't
know what size it is until
you're trying to show
it to somebody.
And also, if you have thousands
of these, which you
technically could, the browser
just starts running into
serious memory problems.
So you have to decide things.
When do you create it?
Do you create it up front
and take an upfront hit?
Do you create it lazily, and
take a hit as people are using
your application?
That often depends on what
you're trying to build.
For example, Gmail takes
a hit up front.
Because they expect you to leave
the tab open for weeks.
Facebook goes the other way,
because it's more of a random
browsing experience.
And they try to make the upfront
hit very small, and
render later.
OK.
So one of the main problems we
have is, if you want to keep
the DOM small, that basically
means you've got to change it
on the fly.
If you have a lot of data to
show, and you don't want to
have a big tree, you've got
to change it on the fly.
And that basically is great.
You've got a nice, small DOM.
But that introduces a whole
bunch of other problems, which
we're going to get into.
One solution people come up
with is have a pool of
reusable DOM elements.
Say you have 20 different
types of
rows you want to show.
Have a pool of each of
them, and reuse them.
So that way you don't go from a
small image to a big image,
back to a small image.
Something with no images,
something with text only.
So this can help.
But you still end up with
kicking off page reflows if
you're not careful.
Also, when you do start changing
things, say you go
from a small bit of text to a
long bit of text, even inside
of something that you haven't
technically changed the
structure of, you can change
the height of it, you can
change the width of it.
And often, you need
to know this.
If you haven't measured
everything ahead of time, then
you need to know how
big something is.
For example, if you want to show
somebody a scroll bar,
they have to know
what size it is.
But the main problem with this
is that touching the
DOM makes Ryan sad.
It makes him very, very sad.
And you don't want
to make Ryan sad.
So measuring the size of a DOM
load, it basically stops
everything.
Makes the browser flush all its
pending operations, and
slows everything down.
So what do we do?
We'd like to keep it
off the UI thread.
This is possible in native.
For example, the Facebook for
iOS app has a completely
separate thread that more or
less does everything the UI
thread does, but does it
off the UI thread.
Measures everything, renders
everything, and then just
passes it over.
That would be lovely.
We can't do that.
One reason is we don't
always have workers
on the latest iOS.
We do on Android.
But we don't always.
Also workers on a single
CPU are slow.
If you're trying to run a worker
on iPhone 4, which only
has a single core, you're not
really getting any gain.
I mean yes, it's different
thread.
But it runs on the same CPU.
And anyway, workers
can't be DOM.
So this doesn't really
help you.
So what can we do?
Hide the scroll bar.
Don't tell people how
much stuff's there.
It's a dirty hack,
but it works.
You don't have to measure a
thousand rows, because just
don't tell them.
Just tell them keep scrolling.
But some people like
scroll bars.
So another thing you can do
is measure when not busy.
This can be fairly tricky.
Because when are you not busy?
You're not touching it now.
What if you start measuring,
you say, I'm going to spend
100 milliseconds measuring
the next X things.
Then in the middle of that 100
milliseconds, someone touches
a page and you miss it because
your JavaScript is running.
You can try and measure in the
middle of a frame, which we've
done before, where we figured,
I spent five milliseconds out
of the 16 or 32 millisecond
frame.
And I'm going to use the
rest to render ahead.
That can work.
But it's really tricky to do.
Something that we're starting to
play with now a bit as well
is measuring on the server,
which is just something we're
only prototyping
at the moment.
But we figure in our use case,
we have at max a few thousand
different ways to arrange all
the individual types of things
on the newsfeed.
And if you have an app like
that, then you can technically
the DOM ahead of time.
Figure out what you fit into.
And just never measure
the DOM at all.
I'm hopeful this might help.
But it doesn't fit
every use case.
But if it does, then measure
things once, and then never
measure them again.
Another annoying thing
is repaints.
Most of this comes in because
images are unpredictable.
They load when you don't want
them to load, like when you're
in the middle of an animation.
They load the wrong size, so
you end up clipping them,
which has its own cost.
Or you end up resizing them,
and it has a massive cost,
which some of the people were
talking about earlier.
Not just network costs, but
obviously performance cost.
And finally, they have
to be decoded.
As we just heard, WebP takes
longer to decode than JPEG,
and JPEG is bad enough
as it is.
So if you're decoding things in
the middle of an animation,
then you're going to
have a bad time.
So what do you do?
Some people defer all
image loading until
you finish an animation.
This is for new images.
That can work.
But it looks bad.
You have a big, empty thing
scrolling by with a little bit
of black text and a
couple of links.
And when you stop, everything
pops in.
It works.
You get nice animation.
And as a start, it's good.
Other people use low res images,
which have a lower
decode cost.
But it still costs paint.
And what we're doing now, or
trying to do, is figure out
how much time each particular
operation, including text
changes and image changes,
take per animation frame.
And we figure we have a 16
millisecond animation frame.
We have used 10 milliseconds.
It normally takes 6
milliseconds to
draw a small image.
So we still have time.
And if we don't, then
we defer it.
And you do get a blank image.
And that gives you the nice
effect of, sometimes you'll
see images scrolling past or
images popping in in the
middle of a scroll.
Sometimes, you don't get to
it, but it tends to look
better than the first one.
That's very hard.
You've got to write
that yourself.
it in JavaScript.
Would be nice if browsers did
these things for you.
But hopefully, we might get
there at some point.
And another one is resizing.
A lot of people think that
resizing images, like just
don't resize.
Don't do it, just clip them.
Often, you can't, as people were
talking about earlier.
Like Jackson was mentioning
at Facebook, we have four
different sizes of images
that we use.
And if you clip them too much,
then it just looks terrible.
You cut off people's heads,
and that kind of thing.
And saying OK, just ship
the right size.
Shipping the right
size is hard.
You've got massive
server costs.
It helps you to be a large
corporation, where you can
tell like Akamai, we really,
really need a solution here.
And they will help you.
If you're not a large
corporation,
you can't do that.
It's very hard to say that if
say I want a 57 by 57 pixel
image, you must serve
it to me.
So one thing you can do is get
designers to calm down a
little bit.
And just tell them, don't try
loading images in subtly
different pixel sizes.
Do you really need a 50
and a 52 pixel image?
Maybe you don't.
Then just have a single 50 pixel
image and you're done.
Designers like to have a free
hand in everything.
But reality has to come into
play at some point.
So one of the final things
is decoding JPEGs.
A lot of people don't
think about this.
A lot of people, they look at
the timeline on Chrome.
And you see a lot of paints
and that kind of thing.
But decoding JPEGs can be a very
large hit, almost as much
as painting sometimes.
One thing we're playing
with is doing
it in a worker thread.
Doing XHR to the server, get
down the data for a JPEG.
Decode it in JavaScript on a
worker thread, ship the data
UI off to the image
on the UI thread.
And then you're only paying
for the paint.
In some cases, that works.
In some cases, it doesn't.
We've only rolled out a test.
But for large images,
it seems to work.
For small images, it doesn't.
It's horrible.
And I wish we could have off
thread JPEG decoding.
But such as it is, it still
slows down our scrolling.
Alex looks thoughtful.
Obviously, there are other
good solutions to this.
But hopefully, the guys will
know some of them.
And the last one that we're
probably going to end up
mentioning is GC, which
everybody knows stands for
Gremlin Carnage.
OK, it really stands for
garbage collection.
But it might as well stand
for Gremlin Carnage.
Because it's just this random
little monster that runs
around, and makes
you very sad.
Unless when he looks really
cute like that, and then
everything's good.
So with garbage collection, you
put all this effort into
having a fantastically good,
smooth animation.
And then something random comes
in and takes up 100
milliseconds and kills
everything.
V8 has, in the last
year or so--
year, 18 months-- come up with
incremental GC, which spreads
the load a bit.
But you still get hit by these
large mark sweep things that
can still take a large
amount of time.
One thing you can do is just
go through your whole code,
and micro-optimize absolutely
every tiny little piece to not
use memory, to reuse events, to
reuse all sorts of things.
It's painstaking.
It takes forever.
And I don't know of
a silver bullet.
But we will be discussing this,
and hopefully somebody
has a silver bullet,
because I want one.
All right.
And with that, let's get
on with the questions.
MATT DELANEY: Thanks, Shane.
So I'm not sure exactly where,
but somewhere out there
there's another mic.
So just keep in mind for this
panel, we have a roving mic
that will magically appear
as you need it.
So we're hoping for even more
people talking in this talk
from the audience, because
everyone deals with
performance.
OK.
So the first question here.
So from our very own Andrew
Betts, we have the first
question which is, with longer
and longer lived pages, will
web developers start having
to spend time on memory
management?
And is that a good thing?
And I'd like to start off Rowan
with this question.
ROWAN BEENJE: Well, I
think Shane, you've
covered some of it there.
I think Shane did cover
some of it there.
We are going to have to worry
a lot more about memory,
especially on memory constraint
stuff like mobile devices.
And the tooling has
got better.
Garbage collection
has got better.
I don't know how much--
AUDIENCE: You had the
mic [INAUDIBLE].
ROWAN BEENJE: I don't know how
much everyone knows about--
I don't know how much everyone
knows about the current memory
implementations.
But it's no longer retain
release stuff.
It's all very nice.
Is anything still attached
to the documents?
So no longer cycles
to worry about.
But you do still have to keep
very careful track of objects,
and make sure you don't have
to attach DOM trees.
Massive memory loss there.
And Chrome tools have got
a lot better in this.
You can do heap snapshots.
You can dip your
heap snapshots.
You can work out where you're
leaking objects in your
application life cycle.
But we are going to have to
worry about a lot more.
As Shane said, reuse isn't
silver bullet.
But it's what we have to work
with for the time being.
MATT DELANEY: Anyone else?
PAVEL FELDMAN: It's a bad thing
that we need to care
about memory.
But it's inevitable.
We'll need to take
care of memory.
And we need to make it a
standard part of our
development practice.
And not only we should care
about the present state, but
about the regressions as well.
Because you don't want to fix
everything, and then lose it
all with some regression bug.
And on the tools front, we are
working on exposing better and
better pictures.
We're currently working on
native memory instrumentation,
so that you saw how much DOM and
strings and resources and
images and decoded images
are taking.
But what we can see is
that apps [? model ?]
is most likely a source of the
memory leak and involved with
memory growth.
So you should be using heap
profiler for that.
And yes, it's complex.
And yes, heap profiling and
memory leak hunting is kind of
a last resort.
You don't want to do that.
But you end up doing it.
And you end up doing it not
only for web, but in any
development platform.
So just make it a standard
practice.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: One thing that
we've run into is that
often, you know when your app
is not doing anything.
And you know that, for example,
right after someone
finishes scrolling, they're
going to stop and read
something for at least 100
milliseconds before they start
doing interactions again.
And one of the things that would
be fantastic is if you
could just say, I know my app
state Now clean it up.
But don't do it in two
seconds time when
they're scrolling again.
Clean up now.
And I know this has been
brought up before, too.
Everybody who ever built a
garbage collector, and they
always say, it's always best
guess, or maybe that isn't the
best time to do it, and all
that kind of stuff.
But being someone who doesn't
actually know how the
internals work, why is that?
PAVEL FELDMAN: I'm not
commenting on the GC,
controlling GC questions.
It's a tough area.
And you should be really
talking to the
virtual machine engineers.
And they have the
official story.
Paul, what is our
official story?
PAUL: I have no idea.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So the answer
that you get from the
[? vendors ?] is always, we are
going to do best for you.
You don't want to control it.
Or otherwise, you will
lead us into trouble.
But you really need to go into
the details, and talk to the
actual engineers.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Do we have
any of them in the room?
MATT DELANEY: This relates
directly to the
next question, it's--
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Or a dozen of
next questions like that.
MATT DELANEY: What's that?
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Or a dozen
of next questions on this.
MATT DELANEY: Right.
So this is kind of an
interesting thing from a
standpoint of perhaps getting
the answer from them.
But the next person asks, which
is Shapir from Israel,
is, should JavaScript be allowed
to explicitly trigger
garbage collection when you
the app is idling, say?
Or if the app knows when
it's OK to do so?
Or should it be allowed to
prevent GC when actually
performing time critical
operations?
So this is currently something
that people don't really have
control over.
But, hear your take on it.
ROWAN BEENJE: I think the only
other thing to bear in mind is
that there are occasions when
the browser is going to have
to garbage collect if it's
running out of memory.
So there's always going
to be points where you
can't control it.
But perhaps we could hint,
I'd like the next 16
milliseconds, perhaps.
Please don't garbage collect
during that time.
AUDIENCE: So do you see
observability as a
major issue at TC39?
So one of the things that I
wind up doing is one of
Google's representatives to
the standards body for
JavaScript.
And so being able to know
exactly when garbage
collection happens has
potentially very serious side
effects for cross-document and
cross-origin communication,
which are not friendly.
There's also the concern that
exposing GC will bake into the
web heuristics which are likely
to be proven wrong
anytime now.
So in the history of V8, we've
gone from having a
generational GC to having
many, many, many other
variance of generational GC.
And if you bake in invariants
in your code based on V8,
they'll be wrong under Nitro.
And they'll be wrong under
IonMonkey, or whatever the
next thing is out of
the next vendor.
And so the optimizations you'll
employ are likely to
get you into a place where not
only will you be wrong in the
future version of the VM that
you're currently attempting to
tickle in the right way, you'll
certainly be wrong on
the other VMs, too.
So it's a nasty place to
end your code base up.
CHRIS LORD: I don't have
anything to add to that.
MATT DELANEY: Have you guys run
into any situations where
you felt like it would be a much
better thing to be able
have control over these?
Because in a lot of native
platforms, you have, of
course, different controls over
the VMs, like say in JVM
and whatnot.
Are there any other times in
your experience where you've
dealt with wanting something
like this?
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah.
It's more from an extremely
high level, rather than be
able to observe specific things,
or even know when it's
going to run.
More from a point of view of
telling it, like you said, I'm
starting to do something
really complicated now.
Just calm down.
And if my memory grows by
another 20 megabytes while
you're waiting to GC, please
wait until I'm finished.
And then feel free to hit
me with a big thing.
I know, it may not
be possible.
But--
AUDIENCE: It can't
be that simple.
Because we're trying to balance
the interests of the
user, who may have triggered
your page to allocate those 20
megabytes, versus, should
they go to swap now?
What else should they be doing
here in order to--
what's the most valuable thing
to do with those 20 megabytes?
And the answer may
not be your app.
You may think it is.
But you may not have a global
view on what the user agent is
doing for the user.
CHRIS LORD: And I think to some
extent here, we're kind
of trying to have our
cake and eat it.
You kind of do have some
control over GC to some
extent, in that you can just not
write things in a way that
will end up with objects
to collect.
It sounds kind of silly.
But that's how like in Java on
Firefox mobile for Android, we
have these problems in a lot
of our codes, like while
you're panning and so
on is Java code.
And if we create a load of
objects during those frames,
then at some point, GC will
comes along at a completely
random time and take more
than a frame's worth of
time to do its work.
And the way we work around
that is just
by not doing that.
We can't change the
garbage collector.
And we probably wouldn't
want to anyway, really.
Because then other things are
going to break, and other
assumptions we've made
are going to break.
You can just write your code
in such a way that it won't
cause a lot of GC.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN:
No, that's true.
Yeah, that's true.
And you should be doing
that anyway.
But it does just get to the
point at some point.
I mean, if you're trying to do
things like I was saying
there, or keep your DOM small,
and have some sort of complex
controller that does all these
things and recycles views and
all that kind of stuff.
You're doing all this to get
around the problem of large
DOM and to avoid repaint, and
get as much reuse as you can.
That inevitably leads to
large memory usage.
If you have static content, like
buttons and icons, and
you're swiping through those.
Absolutely.
But if you simply have megabytes
of data that, as a
person scrolls through, you've
got to show them a piece at a
time, it gets fairly difficult
to start avoiding things.
Even when you cut it down
as much as possible.
CHRIS LORD: I guess you kind
of want to balance the two.
MATT DELANEY: I'm moving on.
So we've got a third question
here, from Jonno
from London, or Yonno?
Is that a person in here?
Yonno?
Anyway.
So we've got a very talked about
topic here, but with
respect to tooling this time.
So when you're using CSS to
manually trigger hardware
acceleration of DOM elements for
animations, for example,
the hack of using translateZ(0),
is there a tool
or any way to measure how this
impacts the users and GPU?
They ask.
Let's start with Feldman.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah.
So you measure it
using timeline.
And I won't comment on whether
it's a good practice or not to
force the hardware
acceleration using that technique.
And Paul can cover that one.
But once you've done that, you
can, in Chrome, and it covers
good part of WebKit, you can use
timeline to measure both
paints times, and just
compare those.
That will obviously depend
on whether you are using
[? retna ?]
or not, size of the screen,
[? whatever, ?]
accelerator.
But you can do that.
You'll need to have an
inventory for that.
Because equipment differs.
And do you want to comment
on the translating?
[? PAUL: ?]
Just one thing about the
translate zed for me is that
the way, certainly in Chrome,
it's handled is that it
creates you a new layer,
but also a layer
with a backing surface.
So that effectively really maps
down to a texture that
needs to be uploaded
to the GPU.
So the net result of this is
that if you've got a translate
zed or across a lot of
elements, on desktop
you might be fine.
Because you've got a lot
more VRAM to play with.
But on mobile, you're going
to get punished.
Because now you've got a lot of
textures that needs to be
uploaded to your GPU.
And the upload time might be
quite slow to get those
textures from the CPU up to
the GPU, depending on the
actual hardware you're
running on.
So it's one of these things
that it's sort
of used with caution.
And it may be that in your
specific implementation it
speeds things up, because you've
got enough VRAM to kind
of cover that debt that you're
kind of creating for yourself.
And it also is good because,
again, in Chrome, if it's
possible, switch the rendering
mode over to thread
compositing, which is often a
good thing, especially if
you've got a lot
of animations.
But you might just see, as
again, a mobile, you might see
it crush your performance
if you do it too much.
CHRIS LORD: Yeah, this is the
same case in Firefox, as well,
where if you add any kind of
transformation, then it will
end up not optimizing it, but
sort of making it appear on
its own layer.
There are other things to
consider, as well, when you're
forcing layers and elements
and that.
If you force something to become
a new layer, you're
also forcing layers to be
underneath it and over it,
depending on the structure
of the document.
And again, depending on the
structure of the document,
you'd also be forcing things
like alpha blending to happen.
You're forcing things like
increased overdraw to happen,
all of these.
And you'd have memory
hit, you'd have
GPU time hit as well.
And at some point, like
translateZ(0) might end up
just being a null op anyway.
ROWAN BEENJE: It is
already on WebKit.
It's been kind of deprecated
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL: Yeah, they may be like--
there are other ways to trigger
the same behavior so
that the warning [? shot ?]
is, this one might
become null.
But developers might gravitate
towards an alternative way of
triggering the same effect.
It is exactly what
you're saying.
It depends on the context of
when you're using it as to
whether it's actually a suitable
thing to do, really.
MATT DELANEY: So there's really
a lot of knowledge
here, and a lot of gotchas,
depending upon the platform
and what they fall down into
doing, what actual rendering
paths, right?
But I guess for this question,
it'd be really interesting to
point out maybe, especially
with people in the more
constrained environments on
mobile, what do you guys see
out there for tooling to measure
the impact of their
apps usage of this hack upon
what they're doing?
CHRIS LORD: This is quite
a difficult thing.
Because GPU behavior is wildly
different, depending on what
vendor you have.
So Firefox does have a profiling
tool built in, which
will profile at the native level
where time is spent.
And it goes into JavaScript,
as well.
So if you run your page or
your web GL app, and you
scroll around with the profiler
enabled and you stop,
you can see where time
is being spent.
But in terms of getting really
granular results,
that's quite hard.
Like GL drivers quite often,
they'll defer work to the
latest point possible.
So you might find that although
you're doing a load
of vertex upload or something,
you're uploading a load of
data to the GPU, or you're
uploading a load of things,
you might find that actually all
of that takes zero time.
And swap takes all
of your time.
Or clear takes all of your time,
or flush, or some other
command where the GPU's like,
right, OK, we can't defer
things any longer.
We have to flush out
all the work.
And we can't really counteract
that without doing, I guess,
other clever things like having
a shim for the GL
functions and the JavaScript,
so that we can log what
commands you are using, and use
some kind of context to
say, well, maybe you shouldn't
be doing all of this.
Maybe you shouldn't be uploading
all of this data
here, or maybe you should think
of using more VPOs and
batching your drawing, rather
than doing lots of separate
drawing and things like this.
But I think it's going to be
quite difficult, nigh on
impossible, to have a really
granular general profiler when
it comes to GPU use.
But yeah, Firefox has
a built in profiler.
If it's not in the current
release, it's probably in 19
or 20, I forget.
And also for the record,
we have incremental GC
also in 19 or 20.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So before
it gets to Firefox,
we have it in Chrome.
And the way you look at it-- so
there is no GPU profiling.
But there are interesting cases
on the timeline where
you see your CPU time spent
for just JavaScript
[? layer ?] painting.
And it all adds up to some
reasonable amount.
And then there is this
transparent bar.
And you don't know why your
frame has been skipped.
And the reason for that is the
browser was waiting for GPU.
We don't really see that
happening a lot in practice,
on non-heavy 3D apps
whatsoever.
So in most cases, first thing
you check is timeline.
And you're most likely OK.
And the detailed GPU profiling
is still ahead
for Chrome, as well.
CHRIS LORD: Yeah.
It's much better on desktop
than it is on mobile.
And most of my experience is
mobile, so I'm probably going
to be speaking from
that perspective.
You worry less.
I guess everything is
better on desktop.
The state of mobile GPUs, at
least certainly on Android,
although it's getting better,
is like Android-based system
tends to use GPUs more.
Like, drivers have some pretty
awful and incorrect behavior,
and just flat out bugs that will
cause things like this.
You'll have hitches that will
be very hard to trace.
And it will come down to
something like, you've
triggered something
which might do--
like it might update
part of a texture.
And that GPU driver subimage
uploads are
actually just terrible.
And you should never do them.
We try and work around these
things, but I don't know.
It's on mobile it's hard.
But on desktop, it's less
of a concern, I guess.
MATT DELANEY: Also we
have a question from
the audience here.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
DJ Fazzyfist.
No, I'm kidding.
[INAUDIBLE]
from Google.
It's also worth noting that for
those of you daring souls
in here who compile Chromium,
that there is access to the
Skia debugger, which is actually
sort of the hardware
GPU compositor.
It's actually amazing
the insight you can
get from Skia debugger.
You can actually see the GPU
performance for each CSS
element on your page.
You can actually see what your
DOM is doing, and what each
button and how long that's
taking on the GPU.
It's amazing insight if you're
seeing problems in this area,
and definitely worth checking
out if you're willing to
compile Chromium.
AUDIENCE: How do you spell it?
AUDIENCE: Skia?
S-K-I-A. Skia debugger,
check it out.
Hi.
MATT DELANEY: Sounds
pretty good.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Does it already
provide traceability from DOM
and CSS literally?
Because it was bound
to instructions.
And you couldn't really trace
it into particular
[? selector ?]
and/or CSS property.
I don't believe you can now.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PETE: Mic?
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Pete.
The latest one that I was
playing with had some
abilities there.
Obviously, the tooling needs to
get better across the board
for getting GPU insight for
these sorts of things.
Since kind of the future of web
compositing performance is
on the GPU anyway.
So for those of you who want
to kind of try out and give
feedback for this early stuff,
definitely check out Skia
debugger and kind of get a
chance to chart where these
tools are going in the future.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So the way it
works pretty much, if I
remember it correctly,
is it logs
everything that is happening.
And then it replays it.
And while replaying, you can
assess the performance of the
instructions that were made.
So basic idea.
CHRIS LORD: I think we do
actually, I remember now, on
the [INAUDIBLE]
last year, we have a similar
tool for recording GPU
behavior and then
playing it back.
But I can't tell you
anything about it.
I've just forgotten, and
it's not finished.
So I think that sounds
really cool.
You're definitely well
ahead there.
ROWAN BEENJE: And I think the
Chrome dev tools are just
starting to expose the
amounts of GP memory
used, is that correct?
That's coming up?
PAVEL FELDMAN: Not yet.
ROWAN BEENJE: But it's coming?
PAVEL FELDMAN: It's
coming, yes.
ROWAN BEENJE: Very soon.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So native memory
instrumentation started
with the renderer.
And the GPU for us is outside
of the renderer.
CHRIS LORD: I'm not sure if--
like, we have, if you go to
About Memory in Firefox,
you'll see lots of details
about where your memory's
being used.
I'm not sure if that goes
to GPU memory, though.
That also works--
I think it works, it should
work-- on mobile.
MATT DELANEY: Great.
So that's quite a bit
about the tooling.
So how about we move over to
the next question, which is
related and kind of touched on a
bit in the beginning of this
one, was, how do you guys feel
about frame developers and
their understanding of which
performance metrics they
should actually be looking
at these days?
Say both, of course on a
desktop, but more importantly
mobile, the more constrained
environment.
Should they be looking,
rendering,
compositing, layout?
How should they be used
in the tools?
CHRIS LORD: I guess there
aren't too many.
We've not done as good a job
as we should have, in that
there aren't tools to measure
certain things that you'd
really want to know.
Or at least, the tools are
things like, oh, just use an
HDMI video capture unit and do
frame analysis, which is
obviously not feasible for
most people, I would say.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Can we turn that
to the audience, and may
I ask, how many of you have
experienced issues,
challenges, profiling, fighting
for rendering
performance?
If you could raise your hand.
Rendering performance?
OK.
And how many of you were
using timeline to
capture what's happening?
OK, so it's pretty much
half of [? us. ?]
So that's your answer.
So half of us realize what needs
to be done tooling wise.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So how would it help me
in a web view iOS?
It's great that we have all
these tools in our browsers,
but a lot of performance
of HTML5 is
in the closed platforms.
So what can we do to get those
closed platforms to get the
cool tools that we're
building?
PAVEL FELDMAN: So those
platforms diverge, especially
on the rendering front.
It is truth.
On the CPU front, though, they
are very much alike.
So you have a good clue on
what's happening in iOS web
view when looking at Chrome,
unless you enable threaded
compositing or something
like that.
And it often gives
you a good clue.
And image decode time will
be proportional.
Because what you're assessing
is basically the CPU and the
architecture of what
you're running on.
So you have some clue.
You have some good
clue on that.
But it is not precise.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: But also what
you should care about, I
don't think should be what any
one tool gives you, or any one
performance metric--
I mean, performance is
not a goal in itself.
Performance should be there to
get you to increase whatever
metric matters to you.
So for example, in Facebook,
the reason we care so much
about scrolling is that we did
a test where we artificially
introduced for some small
number of people, 20, 30
million or something, where
we said, we'll have your
scrolling framework on Android
and iOS, just artificially.
We know you can do 60
FPS on an iPhone 5.
We will give you 30 FPS.
And engagement collapsed.
You would still get--
we didn't introduce jerking,
we just slowed
down the frame rate.
And engagement dropped.
So we said, OK, therefore,
scrolling matters to
engagement.
And engagement is
what matters.
So if what you care about--
test all the different
things for your app
that actually matter.
If speed, time to interaction
is what's important to you,
emphasize for that.
If scrolling is important to
you, and you do stuff like
newsfeed, or any kind of image
heavy thing, then optimize for
not resizing images.
Optimize for not doing paint
reflows on complex content.
If you really care about
TTI, do server render.
It's faster.
So try out 10 different
things.
I know it's time consuming.
But the metric you should
be looking at is
what matters to you.
Do you care that people look
at 50 photos in an hour?
You're a photo app, fine,
optimize for that.
So yeah, I don't think there's
any one sole [? rebuttal ?]
for this stuff.
PAVEL FELDMAN: So the same
happened to Chrome.
We consider scrolling
very important.
And there is actually a tooling
to detect regressions
on that front.
So there is a telemetry, the
remote control for Chrome.
And the rendering team
is using it in
the following matter.
This tool can connect to remote
devices such as Android
phones and Chrome OS and
desktops, different builds,
different versions of builds.
So it connects to those, runs
regression testing, uses
timeline to get raw data back,
and builds the graphs.
And any degrade in that graph
is a show stopper, and we
change that.
[? Regressions ?]
gets rolled out [? of them. ?]
So the same thing that happens
on the vendor front should be
happening on that app front.
And I'm sure it does.
So the metric is scrolling
matches here.
CHRIS LORD: I think, on a slight
tangent, there are some
practical things that are worth
knowing before you even--
MATT DELANEY: 30 seconds.
CHRIS LORD: While you're
making a site.
You should take these things
into consideration.
So it's worth knowing to some
extent what things cause new
stacking context to be
created, for example.
Because if you create a new
stacking context, likelihood
is you're going to create
a new layer, as well.
Not necessarily, but it's a
reasonable kind of rule of
thumb to go by.
Try and reduce the amount
of stacking context.
Try to reduce the amount of, for
example, if you have text,
not having it on a solid
background means that you're
going to force alpha blending,
and you're going to force that
text to be rendered twice.
First optics or anti-aliasing,
maybe not on mobile.
We'd probably just
use grayscale.
But there are lots of little
things like this.
Like if you're going to have
gradients in your backgrounds,
CSS gradients, don't change
them all the time.
Don't resize them if
you can help it.
Try and avoid fixed
backgrounds.
Because again, you're going to
force the foreground layers to
have an alpha channel and force
blending and so on.
Just sort of small tips that--
MATT DELANEY: Lots of good
strategic advice there.
Move on to the next
one here, sorry.
So we've got a pretty
interesting question, I think,
from James Ford.
Kind of an age old question,
perhaps, but does using SVGs
and font icons for graphics over
GIFs and PINGs have an
impact on the performance
of a web page?
How about more from your actual
experience of using such?
CHRIS LORD: I was going to say
recently, we switched SVG to
rather than going from like a
single node in our display
list to using all of our
display list nodes.
So if you have an SVG that's
got like 1,000 different
render nodes in it, then that
will be represented in our
display list.
And we have open bugs.
This did cause performance
issues.
Because as you scroll through
the page and you expose new
areas of SVG, we have to iterate
that whole list, and
render it and sort it into
layers, decide which bits have
changed and which haven't
and so on.
So yeah, SVGs are
going to be--
you can cache them.
But assuming that you're
using them for a reason
and you're not just--
I mean, if you weren't going
to plan on showing them at
different sizes or a site.
Assuming that you are using
SVG for a reason and you
couldn't have just used a static
image kind of thing,
they are more expensive to use
than just static images.
And the same with
fonts, as well.
Fonts are quite expensive
to render.
So the answer is
yeah, I guess.
They're more expensive.
AUDIENCE: So maybe one example
that I found recently,
actually the Apple site uses
SVGs quite well and badly.
Well in the sense that they
use them everywhere, for
example for the logo
and all the rest.
But I think what a lot of people
miss is a complex SVG
with a lot of paths is actually
very expensive, even
in network bytes.
If you look at the complexity of
the SVGs that they use, you
can get like a 5x improvement if
you just save it as a PNG.
So it's retina friendly, which
is what Apple wants.
But it's actually worse off for
like render time of your
page and network performance.
CHRIS LORD: Yeah.
ROWAN BEENJE: Does anyone have
any comparative information
about icon fonts versus SVG?
PAVEL FELDMAN: We
need to measure.
And if we can't measure
it, we need to
make sure we can measure.
MATT DELANEY: [INAUDIBLE]
in the back?
Never mind.
No experience from
Facebook on this?
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: No experience
by me at Facebook
at the very least, no.
MATT DELANEY: All right, so
let's move on to the next
question then.
A little bit of time
here left.
How much on the clock?
15?
So kind of a bit of a loaded
question, but how can I find
which CSS rules and properties
are expensive to render on a
particular page?
Is a next question, a little
bit of clarification.
PAVEL FELDMAN: We are
working on that.
But it's a hard one.
You need to trace it all the way
from the CSS property to
the GL instruction or paint
instruction, Skia instruction.
And it's a long way to go.
There is a permanent solution,
though, that we've introduced
recently as an experiment.
We can now put browser into the
continuous repaint mode,
where it continuously repaints,
even if it doesn't
need to, and it shows you the
frame rate it can do it at.
And if you're not touching a
page, you can see that OK,
where it says number
of milliseconds,
it's paints per frame.
So it says, 3 milliseconds
per frame.
That's a good frame.
You'll achieve 60
FPS with that.
If it shows you 60, or 100
milliseconds, then you can go
and bisect your DOM.
So that's the best we can
offer at the moment.
You go through DOM,
you hide things.
It toggles visibility
to [INAUDIBLE].
And the number of milliseconds
reduce.
And then you figure out what
is the part that was
statically positioned, or had
a complex background, or had
some gradient whatsoever.
It's a manual process.
But it is already way
better than nothing.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Will this help
in the case where you're
showing and hiding things, but
let's say I modify something
that will trigger both a
repaint and a reflow.
Does this capture it
in that second?
PAVEL FELDMAN: So this one
is only about paint.
And paint meaning layout
does not change.
DOM does not change.
So it's only about CSS
and DOM that you have
presented on the screen.
For the rest of the
information,
you go to the timeline.
There are similar techniques
on figuring out the recalc
style or layout performance.
They often end up
with bisecting,
unfortunately, as well.
And we're working on
improving that.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Anything cool
coming up in Firefox?
CHRIS LORD: Not much
to add, really.
On mobile, I guess, it's worth
considering that certain pages
and complex pages, and on
certain mobile devices, it's
really not feasible to expect
the page to render very
quickly, as in within a
reasonable 60 hertz or 30
hertz time frame.
But we have asynchronous
compositing to counter that.
And what your goal then really
is to kind of do your work at
clever times, and partition it
in clever ways so that you
don't interrupt the asynchronous
compositing at
inopportune times,
or for too long.
MATT DELANEY: We're on to
the next question here.
So this is perhaps a little
bit redundant, but it's
interesting to get the
perspective real quick from
both the Chrome and
Firefox person.
So we use translateZ(0) to
trigger hardware rendering, as
people think.
Should we have an API to
explicitly do this?
So this is obviously
a bit tough.
And I think we can get some
audience input to this.
But should there be, perhaps in
general, any feedback from
the app side to get a little
bit of hopeful kick into
acceleration?
Because if people are using
this, and they're finding it
to good effect, is it something
that maybe we want
to make more real?
PAVEL FELDMAN: So I think Paul
and Alex have already covered
this one from the platform
perspective.
When you were talking to GC,
many things applied to this
thing as well.
CHRIS LORD: Yeah.
This has come up a few times,
really, like do we want apps
to be able to hint to
GC when to collect?
And do we want--
it's like every bit of control
that you add is kind of--
MATT DELANEY: From your work
on Android, have you found
times where it would've been
more useful for the app
developer to give you a hint
that they need that?
CHRIS LORD: Not really,
I guess.
I think really, we should
just be cleverer
about doing these things.
I think if you put that kind of
control into users' hands,
things are going to change too
much pretty quickly, to the
point where it would
just force bad
behavior in future versions.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: From the point
of view of people who
write apps, yes, it
would be lovely.
I don't know if it's
feasible or not.
It's just that on the web, as
everybody knows, one of the
reasons we're sitting here right
now is that performance
is a problem.
And on some of the platforms,
you do have the option of
dropping down to a lower level
if you need to, and if you
have people who are
sufficiently good
enough to do so.
And I don't know if that's
feasible on the web.
It would be nice if it was.
I admit, things change
all the time.
We're constantly updating our
browsers, or even updating
them in the background now.
So things do change
all the time.
And even on iOS, things
change once a year.
So yes, it would probably
break everything.
But when you try to do smart
things in general, often
you're going to be missing
an edge case.
And an edge case could be 25%
of all implementations.
So I don't know.
If there was a way to drop down
lower and just say look,
I know what I'm doing, trust
me, it would be great.
Like I said, you can do it
on native platforms.
CHRIS LORD: I guess you've
got Canvas and WebGL.
You can do it like that.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: True.
MATT DELANEY: Is there
maybe time for one
more question here?
So the question from Christina
Auckland, from Hampshire, is
there an overhead to using
media queries, especially
bubbling media queries in
your experience, guys?
PAVEL FELDMAN: I don't know.
CHRIS LORD: No idea.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Not a clue.
MATT DELANEY: Then one
more question.
Oh man.
Nope.
We talked about this question
for about five hours last
night, off and on, like
beating a dead horse.
Would it be possible to
accelerate reflows, hardware
accelerate?
So I think this question's a
bit confused into what it's
asking, perhaps.
But it did bring up some
interesting things last night.
So give you a moment to just
talk about what reflows are,
perhaps from you guys, and how
that may possibly be hardware
accelerated.
PAVEL FELDMAN: I think Google
is definitely hiring.
So if someone has some bright
ideas on that, they'd be
definitely interested.
CHRIS LORD: Ditto.
I guess, yeah, I think
the question
might be slightly confused.
So to kind of go to semi-fast
principles, I'm going to
assume that DOM tree is
something that we all know.
But browsers tend to, after you
get a DOM tree, it will
get passed into a frame tree,
which is a better
representation of how
it will get drawn.
And then the frame tree will get
processed, where it will
calculate where the position
and size of things are.
And that bit is the reflow.
So when you change something
that causes a size to change,
then reflow needs to happen.
Because the size of certain
elements will be dependent on
the other elements.
I say elements, that's
not quite true.
Because we're in the
frame tree now, but
for the most part.
So that's not something
you could put on--
I mean, you could put it
on the GPU, I guess.
But it'd be pretty pointless.
All of that is in
system memory.
So you'd be shoving that over
to GP memory, and writing a
really complex set of shaders,
I guess, to work on it.
And then shovel it back.
Basically, the answer is no.
But maybe there are some other
things that we're not
accelerating right now that we
could, which might be an
interesting question.
So from the frame tree, Firefox,
or Gecko rather, will
make a display list which
represents how it
would draw the page.
And then it processes the
display list to create the
layer tree.
And I think a similar process
happens in WebKit, possibly
minus display list or depending
on what fork you're
using, judging from the
conversation last night.
Are there other things that
we could accelerate, maybe
between those things or like
during that thing?
So for Firefox, most of
the rendering will
happen on your CPU.
Certain things will be hardware
accelerated, like
drawing a big image.
That might end up being uploaded
to the GPU and
scaled, for example,
in the GPU.
Or transforms happen on GPU.
Blending happens on the GPU.
But maybe there are other
things that could
happen on the GPU.
Like we don't draw gradients
on the GPU at the moment.
And gradients are a huge hit.
That's something we
could do, maybe.
And other elements as well.
There might be other element
types that would be able to
take advantage of hardware
accelerated rendering.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Another hint is
that if you're experiencing
really slowly, most likely you
are doing a total reflow.
And in WebKit, you are doing
total reflow if your layout
root is root of the document.
Which means in this very
message, you mutated two ports
of non-intersecting DOMs.
And they ended up being
the root layout.
So you figure out what
your layout root is.
There are simple rules to follow
to make your element
layout root.
And make sure you
don't screw it.
CHRIS LORD: I think we've kind
of mentioned this already.
But just in case, a lot of the
optimizations that happen on
the kind of rendering process
are to do with delaying tasks
and splitting them up.
So things like, if you can make
everything like a set
width and height, and never move
it, that would be great.
But if you do have need to
change something, like if you
change the width of something,
that is going to trigger a
reflow probably at some point.
But that point could be any time
between the time you do
it and the time that
the frame comes.
And stuff might happen
in between.
And if possible, we'll coalesce
these reflows.
On the other hand, if you change
a width, and then you
immediately read back the
width of an element that
depended on that width, you're
forcing that reflow to happen
immediately.
And then if you change something
after that, then
you've got a double
reflow situation.
So I guess an attempt to maybe
batch stuff is a sort of
general tip to avoid that.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah, so to add
to that, we've often seen five
total reflows happen
within a frame.
So it's not that the
reflow is slow.
It's that it's continuously
happening
within the same message.
And we have good
tools for that.
We will show you all the
layouts, and we will show you
[INAUDIBLE] stacks that
invalidated re-layout, and
that forced it.
And you can see a continuous
invocation of
like five of them.
And you cut it into a single
one, and all of a sudden your
performance is OK again.
MATT DELANEY: So actually, real
final question here from
the audience is from Paul
Kinlan, he says, yes, does
scrolling performance in
client-side performance affect
the time on the site, balance
rate, et cetera?
And Shane was actually talking
about something pretty
interesting last night about
what he's seen from Facebook's
perspective.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: Yeah, I kind
of mentioned it a bit earlier.
But yeah, it absolutely does.
What we find on Facebook is that
regardless of what you
do, people have kind of assigned
a certain amount of
time every day to spend
on the site.
And the more things that you can
get them to do within say,
they only spend 20
minutes a day.
And if you can show them twice
as many pages during that day,
then it will do twice
as many things.
The same goes for if people tend
to scroll down, we found
that when they scroll more,
they see more stories.
They click like more, they
comment on more things.
They see people's faces,
and the site
sends them more messages.
And when we did add friction
to scrolling, when we added
varying scroll rates, or when
we added consistently slow
scroll rates, as soon as we made
anything non-optimal when
it comes to scrolling, then
people often might stay on the
site as long.
So it didn't really affect
bounce rates.
But they would do far fewer
things, which is why we spend
so much time obsessing
about scroll rates.
So scroll rates directly affect
user engagement on
native, on wave,
on everything.
Which means our basic site,
which only serves HTML and
goes on to Nokia phones, gets
fantastic engagement if you
put it on an iPhone.
It's extremely fast.
It's tiny.
It looks ugly.
And people engage with it
really, really quickly.
And you know what?
It scrolls at 60 frames
per second.
Because there's no JavaScript.
Yeah, who knew?
MATT DELANEY: Any
last thoughts?
CHRIS LORD: Not really.
Maybe it'd be nice, like
we're talking a lot
about scrolling here.
It's obviously very important.
And scroll behavior differs
between basically every mobile
browser in quite big ways.
Maybe this is something we
should be, or should have been
collaborating on before.
Maybe there should be an API
for that, like some kind of
meta tag or something.
SHANE O'SULLIVAN: I heard Chrome
team were going to
start looking at scroll
performance as something to
instrument, or something
like that.
PAVEL FELDMAN: Yeah, so that
telemeter that I was talking
about is the regression testing
for the scrolling
performance.
And there is a huge scrolling
effort that, among other
things, moved the painting to
the impulse side, including
the image decode and resize.
And that's already available
on Chrome for Android now.
Yeah, it's already enabled
for Chrome for Android.
It's in the About Flags
on the desktop Chrome.
So you can take a
look at that.
CHRIS LORD: Sorry, and
one last thing I just
remembered as well.
In the Firefox built in profile,
we have a mode that
we call junk mode, the
like ticker box.
And then when you start the
profiler and you do some
stuff, and you stop it, it
will basically show you--
it will highlight on
the profile exactly
any hitches in panning.
So any frame that took longer
than 16 milliseconds or
whatever to draw.
You can drill down into just the
operations that were going
on during that frame.
And I think, no yeah,
I'm sure, that
profiler works over ADB.
So you can run it on your phone
and profile it on the
desktop, which is
pretty handy.
So just letting you know.
MATT DELANEY: So thanks.
That was Performance Channel.